ah
[Música]
costa rica- funge como anfitrión y
lidera un foro de alto nivel en el día
de la lucha contra la desertificación en
el que líderes políticos internacionales
y del mundo ambiental promoverán
esfuerzos de restauración de las tierras
para la próxima década la actividad
destacará que invertir en la gestión
sostenible de la tierra y el agua en los
años post pandémica puede impulsar una
recuperación económica que produzca
empleos pero que también proteja a las
sociedades de las crisis causadas por el
cambio climático la degradación de la
tierra y la pérdida de la biodiversidad
costarrica compartirá cómo ha
implementado políticas públicas para
proteger la naturaleza convirtiéndose en
el primer país tropical en detener y
revertir su deforestación y degradación
forestal hoy día los bosques cubren más
del 54 por ciento de la superficie de la
nación y más del 26 por ciento del
territorio nacional está protegido por
ley la degradación de la tierra ha
reducido la productividad del 23 por
ciento de la superficie terrestre
mundial por lo que la convención de
naciones unidas de lucha contra la
desertificación organiza estos esfuerzos
para revertir los serios estragos como
la pobreza
escasez de agua y alimentos
[Música]
argentina es por superficie el octavo
país más grande del mundo cerca del 70%
de su territorio está ocupado por
tierras secas que tienen algún tipo de
déficit de agua gran parte de ellas
sufre procesos de desertificación entre
sus causas se encuentran la
intensificación de la ganadería la
expansión de la frontera agropecuaria y
las causas naturales como el efecto del
viento estos procesos tienen un impacto
sobre los ecosistemas de esas tierras y
afectan directamente a las poblaciones
que habitan en esas zonas en argentina
existen una serie de iniciativas para
intentar poner freno a la
desertificación y recuperar tierras
desertificadas en el corazón de ellas
está el programa de acción nacional de
lucha contra la desertificación creado
en el año 2003 ese programa estatal
trabaja en varios frentes como la
educación y la concientización y también
en mitigación y prevención de la
degradación de los suelos y en la
promoción del manejo sustentable de los
suelos
[Música]
a lo largo de este siglo los tres
puertos de españa están en riesgo de
convertirse en desierto y la escasez de
agua aumentará poco a poco en españa el
70% de las demarcaciones hidrográficas
ya sufren la falta de lluvias según la
agencia europea del medio ambiente la
península ibérica' será la región
europea más afectada por el aumento de
episodios de sequía varias prácticas son
responsables como la sobreexplotación de
recursos hídricos la agricultura
intensiva y la urbanización irracional
para luchar el congreso ha aprobado la
ley del gobierno sobre el cambio
climático prevé alcanzar el cero neto de
emisiones en 2040 y acelerar el fin de
los combustibles fósiles
para greenpeace no es suficiente la ong
pide la transformación profunda de las
estrategias de gestión del agua y el
combate de los pozos ilegales
[Música]